well with just six days to go until the
midterm elections president Trump begins
a final campaign push tonight he'll be
in Florida campaigning for Republican
candidate for governor Ron de santis and
other GOP nominees he plans 11 rallies
before Election Day to help Republicans
keep control of Congress House
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi predicted
victory surprise for her party on CBS's
Late Show with Stephen Colbert last
night well let me say this up until
today I would have said if the election
were held today we would win what
happened today that changed that but now
I'm saying is we will win ed O'Keefe is
with us from Washington to explain to us
what exactly that means because she
seemed to say the same thing twice and
it is constitutionally required for a
party leader to say they are going to
win this so given that is she right to
be confident not necessarily because
again while we project that Democrats
are going to retake the house the only
way that happens this year is if
Democrats meet and exceed turnout that
we've seen in previous midterm or non
presidential elections and that is a
high bar in several of these states
where they're trying to win seats again
they need to net 23 seats in order to
retake the majority that sounds like
very little but given the way the maps
are drawn across the country they look
like lizards or snakes or paint on a
wall and they've been drawn by
Republicans to advantage them it's going
to be tricky in some of these races to
find enough Democrats and left-leaning
independents to show up so yes she is
paid to say that she has to say that but
she isn't necessarily correct until we
see exactly who is showing up to vote
that's that's the question I was
thinking I'm thinking now about the
Millennials ad you know the statistics
show that 40% of them will turn up how
important is a millennial vote because
they are a big number yeah big number
and really the future biggest voting
bloc in this country some survey
suggests they say they're going to show
up others say they don't but that's like
asking a kid are you gonna eat your peas
yeah sure I'm gonna eat your peas and
then they don't eat their Peas okay
see again whether they show up or not
but surveys suggest history has shown
that the young folks don't necessarily
show up to vote is this year any
different could be but again we won't
know till Tuesday
and you sound skeptical I can tell you
tell you what Republicans don't want to
be talking about and that is congressman
Stephen King what is the controversy
that he is in right now look this Iowa
congressman has a history of saying
incendiary things about immigrants
associating himself or sounding
sympathetic to white nationalists most
recently he met with members of a
far-right Austrian political party and
met with them during a trip that was
essentially a Holocaust education trip
and then later said something to the
effect of if these guys were Americans
they'd be Republicans well that sparked
a bit of a concern from top Republicans
the guy who's in charge of getting House
Republicans elected across the country
yesterday said those are exactly the
kind of comments we don't need King
clarified his comments in the statements
saying look you know we're all human
beings and and this has just been
whipped up by the fake news bottom line
King probably holds on in a district
again that favors Republicans but he is
facing probably the reelection of his
life he hasn't spent much money his
Democrat opponent has spent far more
than he has and in these closing days
his facing greater scrutiny and
questions about whether he really is fit
to be in office yeah let's go back to
what your mom said words matter thank
you very much Edie good to see you